Elon is getting sued by Twitter  employees and Elon is furious  ex-employees sued Elon claiming the  extreme short notice was illegal under  State labor laws but Elon is claiming no  this just isn't true anyone fired from  Twitter was offered up to three months  to severance pay that's 50 more than the  law requires and the reason for the  short notice Twitter was losing 4  million dollars a day trying to pay its  bills and when you look at the average  income of their software Engineers it  kind of starts to make sense but  apparently after firing over 3 000  people in one day he is asking some of  them to come back please subscribe to  find out what happens next